Kaddish for Naomi Ginsberg, 1894-1956.
《卡迪什》，献给娜奥米·金斯伯格（1894-1956）。
This is the way we usually think about death. We stare at it, trying to comprehend. Here's Allen Ginsberg.
这就是我们通常看待死亡的方式。我们注视着它，试图去理解。这位是艾伦·金斯伯格。
Strange now to think of you, gone without corsets and eyes, while I walk on the sunny pavement of Greenwich Village.
现在想起你，真是陌生，你已离去，没有了束身衣，没有了双眼，而我正走在格林威治村阳光明媚的人行道上。
downtown Manhattan, clear winter noon, and I've been up all night, talking, reading Kaddish aloud, listening to Ray Charles--
曼哈顿市中心，晴朗的冬日正午，我彻夜未眠，一直在交谈，大声朗读《卡迪什》，听着雷·查尔斯的音乐——
When we think about death, we stare at the two images in our head over and over. The person we knew alive, breathing and talking, and the thought of them dead. And we take these two pictures and we turn them around and around, shuffle one on top of the other, trying to understand. How did this living person become that dead one?
当我们思考死亡时，脑海中会反复浮现出两幅画面。一个是活着时我们认识的人，呼吸着，交谈着；另一个是关于他们死去的想法。我们拿着这两幅画面，翻来覆去地看，把它们重叠在一起，试图弄明白。这个活生生的人是怎么变成那个死者的？
The early part of Allen Ginsberg's poem, "Kaddish," mourning his dead mother, is a series of these images.
艾伦·金斯伯格的诗作《卡迪什》的前半部分，是在哀悼他已故的母亲，由一系列这样的意象组成。
--with the YPSL's hitch-hiking thru Pennsylvania, in black baggy gym skirt pants, a photograph of 4 girls holding each other round the waste, laughing eye, too coy, virginal solitude of 1920
——和YPSL（青年社会主义者联盟）的成员们搭车穿过宾夕法尼亚，穿着黑色的宽松运动裤，那是四位姑娘腰间互相搂着的一张照片，眼中带着笑意，过于羞怯，1920年那处女般的孤独。
all girls grown old, now, and that long hair in the grave--
姑娘们如今都已老去，那长发已埋入坟墓——
This is the way we usually think about death. But there's another way. Death isn't just a mystery, a tragedy. It's also a business. Somebody has to sell embalming supplies, somebody has to drive a hearse, somebody has to kill cows for beef, and kill cockroaches in people's houses.
这就是我们通常看待死亡的方式。但还有另一种方式。死亡不仅仅是一个谜团、一场悲剧，它也是一种生意。总得有人销售防腐用品，总得有人开灵车，总得有人为了牛肉宰牛，有人还得在别人家里消灭蟑螂。
Welcome to WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, The Business of Death, people who work with the dead, people who see death every day. Do they know anything about it that we don't?
欢迎收听芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的主题是“死亡生意”，讲述那些与死者打交道、每天面对死亡的人们。他们是否知道一些我们所不知道的关于死亡的事？
Act One of our program, The Undertaking. Funeral director Thomas lynch conducts his own father's funeral. Act Two, The Forbidden Zone. Writer Michael Lesy tells us about his own journey to figure out what autopsy pathologists, homicide detectives, slaughterhouse workers, and others who deal with death know about death. Act Three, Fireman Larry Brown. Act Four, writer David Sedaris explains how to sneak a corpse into a four star hotel, and why you might want to, and how his friends actually have. And Act Five, The Happiest Death Worker, proving that it's all not doom and gloom in the death biz. Stay with us.
节目第一幕，《承办方》。殡仪馆馆长托马斯·林奇主持了他父亲的葬礼。第二幕，《禁区》。作家迈克尔·莱西讲述了他的旅程，去了解尸检病理学家、凶杀案侦探、屠宰场工人和其他人是如何看待死亡的。第三幕，《消防员拉里·布朗》。第四幕，作家大卫·塞达里斯解释如何把一具尸体偷偷运进五星级酒店，以及为什么要这么做，还有他的朋友们是如何做到的。第五幕，《最快乐的死亡工作者》，证明死亡生意并非全是阴郁和黑暗。请继续收听。
Act One, The Undertaking. When researching today's show, one of our producers talked with a funeral director who said at one point, well, you know, all funeral directors are either alcoholics or born-agains. Which seems like an exaggeration, but clearly this is a job with some pressure and stress to it that takes its toll on many people.
第一幕，《承办方》。在筹备今天的节目时，我们的一位制片人采访了一位殡仪馆馆长，他曾说：“嗯，你知道，所有殡仪馆馆长要么是酒鬼，要么是重生信徒。”这听起来像是夸张，但显而易见，这是一份压力巨大的工作，很多人为此付出了代价。
Well, Thomas Lynch is an undertaker in Milford, Michigan. He says that it is not the sort of job where you get rich, usually. He says you can afford an orthodontist for your kids but not boarding school. And so, he says, you do not stay in this job unless you get some sort of satisfaction from it.
托马斯·林奇是密歇根州米尔福德的一名殡葬业者。他说，这通常不是那种能让你发财的工作。他说你也许付得起孩子的牙医费用，但供不起寄宿学校。所以他说，如果你不能从中获得某种满足感，你就不会留在这份工作上。
Most people, he says, could not be paid enough to embalm a neighbor on Christmas, stand with a widower at his wife's open casket, talk with a leukemic mother about her fears for her children about to be motherless. He says that the ones who stay with this work believe that they actually are helping the living in some way by burying their dead.
他说，大多数人就算给再多钱，也不愿在圣诞节为邻居进行防腐处理，不愿在敞开的棺材前陪伴鳏夫，也不愿和一位患白血病的母亲谈论她对即将失去母亲的孩子们的担忧。他说，那些留在这份工作中的人，相信他们通过安葬死者，确实是在以某种方式帮助活着的人。
The undertakers are over on the other island. They are there for what is called their Midwinter Conference. The name they give to the week in February every year when funeral directors from Michigan find some warm place in the Lesser Antilles to discuss the pressing issues of their trade. The names for the workshops and seminars are borderline. "The Future of Funeral Service," "What Folks Want in a Casket," "Coping with the Cremation Crowd," things like that. The resorts must have room service, hot tubs, good beaches and shopping on site or nearby. No doubt, it is the same for orthodontists and trial lawyers.
殡仪馆馆长们在另一个岛上。他们正在参加所谓的“仲冬会议”。这是他们每年二月给那一周起的名字，那时密歇根州的殡仪馆馆长们会寻找小安的列斯群岛中温暖的地方，讨论他们行业中紧迫的问题。研讨会和讲座的名字听起来都有些边缘化。“殡葬服务的未来”、“人们在棺材方面的需求”、“如何应对火葬人群”，诸如此类。度假村必须有客房服务、热水浴缸、良好的海滩和现成的购物点。毫无疑问，牙医和出庭律师也是如此。
And I'm here on the neighboring island, a smaller place, with a harbor too shallow for cruise ships and no airport. I'm a ferry boat ride from the undertakers from my home state. But I've timed my relief from the Michigan winter with theirs in case I want to register for a meeting and write-off my travel.
我就在邻近的岛上，一个更小的地方，港口太浅，无法停靠游轮，也没有机场。我离家乡那些殡葬业者只有一趟渡轮的距离。但我把逃离密歇根冬天的计划和他们同步了，以防我想注册参加会议并抵扣差旅费。
My father was a funeral director, and three of my five brothers are funeral directors, and two of my three sisters work pre-need and bookkeeping in one of the four funeral homes around the metro area that bear our name, our father's name. It is an odd arithmetic, a kind of family farm working the back 40 of the emotional register. Our livelihoods depending on the deaths of others in the way that medicos depend on sickness, lawyers on crime, the clergy on the fear of God.
我父亲是一名殡仪馆馆长，我的五个兄弟中有三个也是，我的三个姐妹中有两个在大都会地区我们家名下的四家殡仪馆之一从事预购业务和记账工作。这是一种奇特的算术，就像一种经营着情感领域最后一片荒地的家族农场。我们的生计取决于他人的死亡，就像医生依赖疾病，律师依赖犯罪，神职人员依赖对上帝的敬畏一样。
My father died three years ago on an island off the Gulf Coast of Florida. He wasn't exactly on a Midwinter Conference. He'd quit going to those years before, after my mother had died. But he was sharing a condo with a woman friend, who always overestimated the remedial powers of sexual aerobics. Or maybe she only underestimated the progress of his heart disease. We all knew it was coming.
我父亲三年前在佛罗里达州墨西哥湾沿岸的一个岛上去世了。他并不是真的去参加什么仲冬会议。他在我母亲去世后几年就不再去那些会议了。但他和一个女性朋友合住一套公寓，那个女人总是高估“性有氧运动”的补救功效。又或者，她只是低估了我父亲心脏病恶化的程度。我们都知道这一天会来。
In the first year of his widowhood, he sat in this chair, heartsore, waiting for the other shoe to drop. Then he started going out with women. The brothers were glad for him. The sisters rolled their eyes a lot. In the two years of consortium that followed, he'd had a major-- which is to say, a chest-ripping, down for the count-- heart attack every six months, like clockwork. He survived all but one. Three out of four, I can hear him saying. You're still dead when it's over. He'd had enough.
在他丧偶的第一年里，他伤心地坐在椅子上，等待着另一只靴子落地（指等待不幸发生）。后来他开始和女性交往。兄弟们为他感到高兴。姐妹们对此直翻白眼。在随后的两年交际中，他每六个月就会像定时钟一样发生一次重大的——也就是那种撕裂胸腔、彻底瘫倒的——心脏病发作。他撑过了四次中的三次。我能听到他说：“三局两胜，结束时你还是会死。”他已经受够了。
When we got the call from his woman friend, we knew what to do. My brother and I had done the drill in our heads before. We had a traveling kit of embalming supplies, gloves, fluids, needles, odds and ends. We had to explain to the security people at the airlines who scrutinized the contents of the bag, wondering how we might make a bomb out of Dodge Permaglow or overtake the cabin crew with a box marked "Slaughter Surgical Supplies," full of stainless steel oddities they'd never seen before.
当我们接到他那位女性朋友的电话时，我们知道该怎么做。我和我兄弟在脑海中演练过这个过程。我们有一个装满防腐用品、手套、液体、针头以及各种杂物的旅行工具箱。我们不得不向那些审视包内物品的航空公司安检人员解释，他们担心我们怎么能用“道奇Permaglow”做成炸弹，或者用标着“屠宰手术用品”的盒子劫持机组人员，因为里面装满了他们从未见过的不锈钢奇形怪状的东西。
When we got to the funeral home they had taken him to, taken his body to, the undertaker there asked if we were sure we wanted to do this, our own father, after all. He'd be happy to call in one of his own embalmers. We assured him it would be OK. It was something we had always promised him. Though I can't now, for the life of me, remember the context in which it was made. The promise that when he died his sons would embalm him, dress him, pick out a casket, lay him out, prepare the obits, contact the priest, manage the flowers, the casseroles, the wake and procession, the Mass and burial. Maybe it was just understood.
当我们到达他们带他去的殡仪馆时，那里的殡仪馆馆长问我们是否确定要这样做——毕竟那可是我们的亲生父亲。他很乐意叫他自己的一位防腐师来。我们向他保证没问题。这是我们一直向他承诺过的事情。虽然我现在死活想不起来是在什么背景下做出的承诺。承诺说当他去世时，他的儿子们要亲自为他防腐、穿衣、挑选棺材、为他整容、准备讣告、联系牧师、处理鲜花、安排餐饮、守灵和送葬、主持弥撒和安葬。也许这只是心照不宣。
His was a funeral he would not have to direct. It was ours to do. And though he directed thousands of them, he had never made mention of his own preferences. Whenever he was pressed on the matter, he would only say, you'll know what to do. We did.
他的葬礼是他不需要亲手指挥的一场。这是我们的任务。虽然他指挥过成千上万场葬礼，但他从未提过自己的偏好。每当有人追问此事，他只会说：“你们会知道怎么做的。”我们确实知道。
I had seen my father horizontal before. At the end, it had been intensive care units, mostly, after his coronaries and bypass. He'd been helpless, done unto. But seeing him outstretched on the embalming table of the Andersen Mortuary in Fort Myers, with the cardiac blue in his ears and fingertips, and along his distal regions, shoulders, and lower ribs, and buttocks, and heels, I thought, this is what my father will look like when he's dead. And then, like a door slammed shut behind you, the tense of it all shifted into the inescapable present of, this is my father, dead. Then we went to work in the way our father had trained us.
我以前见过横卧着的父亲。在最后阶段，那主要是在重症监护室，在他心脏病发作和做完搭桥手术之后。他曾那么无助，任人摆布。但看到他躺在迈尔斯堡安德森殡仪馆的防腐台上，耳朵、指尖、远端部位、肩膀、下肋、臀部和脚后跟呈现出心脏病发作时的青紫色时，我想：这就是我父亲死后的样子。然后，就像身后砰地关上了一扇门，那种时态瞬间切换成了无法逃避的现在时：这是我的父亲，他死了。然后我们按照父亲训练我们的方式投入了工作。
He was a cooperative body. Despite the arterial sclerosis, his circulatory system made the embalming easy. And having just stepped from the shower into his doom, he was clean and cleanly shaven. He hadn't been sick in the hospice or intensive care sense of the word, so there were none of the bruises on him or tubes in him that medical science can inflict and install.
他的身体很配合。尽管有动脉硬化，但他的循环系统使得防腐过程很容易。而且他刚洗完澡就走向了终点，所以他很干净，胡须也刮得干干净净。他在临终关怀或重症监护意义上并没有生病，所以他身上没有医学手段可能造成的瘀伤或插管。
He'd gotten the death he wanted, caught in full stride, quick and cleanly, after a day strolling the beach picking sea shells for the grandchildren and, maybe, after a little bone bouncing with his condo mate. Though she never said, and we never asked and can only hope. And massaging his legs, his hands, his arms, to affect the proper distribution of fluid and drainage, watching the blue clear from his fingertips and heels, as the fluid that would preserve him long enough for us to take our leave of him worked its way around his body, I had the sense that I was doing something for him, even though, now dead, he was beyond my kindnesses or anyone's.
他得到了他想要的死亡，在全速前进中猝然倒下，干净利落。那一天他还在海滩上散步，为孙辈们捡贝壳，也许还和他的同居伴侣共享了鱼水之欢。虽然她没说，我们也从未问过，只能心存希冀。当按摩他的双腿、双手和双臂以使液体和引流物正确分布时，看着青紫色从他的指尖和脚后跟消退，随着那种能让他防腐足够长久以便我们与他告别的液体在他身体里流转，我感到我是在为他做些什么。尽管现在他已经死了，超越了我的善意或任何人的善意。
Likewise, his body bore a kind of history. The tattoo, with my mother's name on it, he'd had done as an 18-year-old Marine during World War II, the perfectly trimmed mustache I used to watch him darken with my mother's mascara, when he was younger than I am and I was younger than my children are. There were the graying chest hairs, the hairless ankles, the male pattern baldness I see on the heads of men in the first-class section of airplanes and in the double mirrors in the barber shop. Embalming my father I was reminded of how we bury our dead and then become them. In the end, I had to say that, maybe, this is what I'm going to look like dead.
同样，他的身体承载着某种历史。那个纹着我母亲名字的纹身，是他二战时18岁当海军陆战队员时纹的；那副修剪得完美的胡须，我小时候曾看着他用我母亲的睫毛膏把它涂黑，那时他比我年轻，而我比我的孩子们年轻。还有灰白的胸毛、无毛的脚踝、我在飞机头等舱和理发店双面镜里看到的男士脱发。给父亲防腐时，我想起我们是如何安葬死者，然后又变成他们的。最终，我不得不说，也许这就是我死后的样子。
Maybe it was at a Midwinter Conference my father first thought about what he did and why he did it. He always told us that embalming got to be, forgive me, de rigueur during the Civil War when, for the first time in our history, lots of people, mostly men, mostly soldiers, were dying far from home and the families that grieved them. Dismal traders worked in the tents on the edges of the battlefields, charging to disinfect, preserve, and restore dead bodies. Which is to say, they closed mouths, sutured bullet holes, stitched limbs or parts of limbs back on, and sent the dead back home to wives and mothers, fathers and sons.
也许是在某次仲冬会议上，我父亲第一次思考他做了什么以及为什么这么做。他总是告诉我们，防腐处理是在南北战争期间变得——请原谅我用这个词——流行的，因为那是我们历史上第一次有大量的人，主要是男性，主要是士兵，死在远离家乡和哀悼他们的亲人的地方。阴沉的商人坐在战场边缘的帐篷里，收费进行消毒、保存和修复尸体。也就是说，他们闭上嘴巴、缝合弹孔、将断肢重新缝合，然后把死者送回妻子、母亲、父亲和儿子身边。
All of this bother and expense was predicated on the notion that the dead need to be at their obsequies, or, more correctly, that the living need the dead to be there, so that the living can consign them to the field or fire after commending them to God, or the gods, or whatever is out there. The presence and participation of the dead human body at its funeral is, as my father told it, every bit as important as the bride's being at her wedding, the baby at its baptism.
所有这些麻烦和开支都基于一个观念，即死者需要出席他们的葬礼，或者更准确地说，活着的人需要死者出席，这样活着的人才能在将他们托付给上帝、诸神或无论什么超自然存在之后，把他们安葬在土地或火焰中。正如我父亲所说，死者躯体在葬礼上的出席和参与，就像新娘出现在婚礼上、婴儿出现在洗礼上一样重要。
A man that I work with, named Wesley Rice, once spent all of one day and all night carefully piecing together the parts of a girl's cranium. She'd been murdered by a madman with a baseball bat after he'd abducted and raped her. The morning of the day it all happened, she'd left for school dressed for picture day. A school girl, dressed to the nines, waving at her mother, ready for the photographer.
和我一起工作的一个叫韦斯利·赖斯的人，曾经花了一整天加一整夜的时间，小心翼翼地把一个女孩破碎的头骨拼凑起来。她被一个疯子用棒球棍残忍杀害了，在此之前，那个疯子绑架并强奸了她。那一天早上，她穿着拍照日用的衣服去学校。一个穿着整齐、向母亲挥手告别的女学生，准备去拍照。
The picture was never taken. She was abducted from the bus stop and found a day later in a stand of trees just off the road, a township south of here. The details were reported dispassionately in the local media, along with the speculations as to which of the wounds was the fatal one, the choking, the knife, or the baseball bat. No doubt, these speculations were the focus of the double postmortem the medical examiner performed on her body before signing the death certificate, multiple injuries.
那张照片永远没能拍成。她在公交车站被绑架，一天后被发现弃尸在离这里一个乡镇不远处的树林里。当地媒体不带感情色彩地报道了细节，并推测哪一处伤是致命伤：是窒息、刀伤还是棒球棍造成的。毫无疑问，这些推测是验尸官在签署死亡证明之前对她的遗体进行双重尸检的焦点：多处创伤。
Most embalmers, faced with what Wesley Rice was faced with after we'd opened the pouch from the morgue, would have simply said, closed casket, treated the remains enough to control the odor, zipped the pouch, and gone home for cocktails. It would've been easier. The pay was the same. Instead, he started working. 18 hours later, the girl's mother, who had pleaded to see her, saw her.
大多数防腐师面对韦斯利·赖斯从停尸房打开袋子后看到的情景时，可能都会简单地说：“封棺”，对遗体做足以控制气味的简单处理，拉上袋子就去喝鸡尾酒了。那样会更容易，工资也一样。但他开始工作了。18小时后，那个哭求见女儿最后一面的女孩母亲，见到了她。
She was dead, to be sure, and damaged. But her face was hers again, not the madman's version. The hair was hers, not his. The body was hers, not his. Wesley Rice had not raised her from the dead nor hidden the hard facts, but he had retrieved her death from the one who had killed her. He had closed her eyes, her mouth. He'd washed her wounds, sutured her lacerations, pieced her beaten skull together, stitched the incisions from the autopsy, cleaned the dirt from under her fingernails, scrubbed the fingerprint ink from her fingertips, washed her hair, dressed her in jeans and a blue turtleneck, and laid her in a casket beside which her mother stood for two days and sobbed as if something had been pulled from her by force.
她确实死了，而且伤痕累累。但她的脸庞找回了原来的样子，不再是那个疯子蹂躏后的版本。头发是她自己的，不是他的。身体是她自己的，不是他的。韦斯利·赖斯既没有让她死而复生，也没有掩盖残酷的事实，但他从杀人犯手中夺回了她的死亡。他闭上了她的双眼和嘴巴，洗净了她的伤口，缝合了撕裂伤，拼好了被打碎的头骨，缝合了尸检的切口，清理了指甲下的泥土，洗掉了指尖的指纹墨水，洗净了头发，给她穿上牛仔裤和蓝色高领毛衣，把她安置在棺材里。她的母亲在棺材旁站了两天，抽泣着，仿佛有什么东西被强行从她身上剥离。
It was then, and always will be, awful, horrible, unappeasably sad. But the outrage, the horror, the heartbreak belonged not to the murderer, or the media, or the morgue, each of whom had staked their claims to it. It belonged to the girl and to her mother. Wesley had given them the body back. What Wesley Rice did was a kindness. It served the living by caring for the dead.
那在当时，而且永远都是，令人难过、可怕、无尽悲伤的事。但愤怒、恐惧和心碎并不属于凶手、媒体或停尸房，尽管他们各自宣称拥有这些权利。它属于那个女孩和她的母亲。韦斯利把尸体还给了她们。韦斯利·赖斯所做的是一种仁慈。它通过关怀死者来服务生者。
Over on the other island, they are trying to reinvent the funeral as a vehicle for the healthy expression of grief, which, of course, it is. Or as a brief therapy for the acutely bereaved, which, of course, it is. There will be talk of stages, steps, recovery. Maybe I'll take the boat over tomorrow. Maybe some of the old timers are there, men of my father's generation, men you could call in the middle of the night if there was trouble. They remind me of my father. Maybe they'll say I remind them of him.
在另一个岛上，他们试图重新发明葬礼，将其作为一种健康表达哀悼的方式——当然确实如此。或者作为一种对急剧丧亲者的短期疗法——当然也确实如此。那里会有关于阶段、步骤、恢复的讨论。也许我明天会坐船过去。也许那里有一些老前辈，和我父亲那一代人一样，如果你半夜遇到麻烦可以打电话求助的人。他们让我想起我父亲。也许他们会说我让他们想起了他。
Thomas Lynch, reading from his memoir, The Undertaking , which will be published in July by Norton.
托马斯·林奇，朗读自他的回忆录《承办方》，该书将于七月由诺顿出版社出版。
Act Two, The Forbidden Zone. In a certain sense, writer Michael Lesy is in the business of death himself. He's the author of, Wisconsin Death Trip , The Forbidden Zone , and other writings which either touch on or obsess over the subject. In his book, The Forbidden Zone , he heads out to talk with all sorts of people in the business of death-- autopsy pathologists, executioners on death row, mercenaries, undertakers, homicide detectives-- on a quest of understanding.
第二幕，《禁区》。从某种意义上说，作家迈克尔·莱西自己也身处死亡行业。他是《威斯康星死亡之旅》、《禁区》以及其他触及或沉迷于该主题的作品的作者。在他的书《禁区》中，他出发去采访各种各样身处死亡行业的人——尸检病理学家、死刑执行官、雇佣兵、殡仪馆馆长、凶杀案侦探——进行一场理解之旅。
I wanted to find out how people bear the facts of death. My father, who I loved very dearly, was very, very old. And he was going to die, and very soon, I thought. And I thought that I could bear it more easily if I went out and talked to people who dealt with death professionally. Because I thought, maybe, they knew things that I didn't.
我想弄清楚人们是如何承受死亡的事实。我深爱的父亲非常、非常老了。我想他很快就会去世。我以为，如果我去和那些专业从事死亡工作的人交谈，我可能会更容易承受。因为我心想，也许他们知道一些我不知道的事情。
Let me ask you to read from a scene where you go to an autopsy. Let me ask you to turn to page 33 in the book. Because this is a fairly typical kind of a scene of the sort of things that you would encounter when you would go out.
让我请你读一段你去参加尸检的场景。请翻到书的第33页。因为这是那种你出去采访时会遇到的相当典型的场景。
The radio was on to a rock station. There was a bearded man sitting hunched over the second autopsy table, finishing a post.
收音机里放着摇滚乐。第二张解剖台旁蹲着一个留胡子的男人，正在完成一场尸检。
Post, meaning a?
尸检，是指？
A postmortem. --On a 20 week old fetus that had been spontaneously aborted the night before. The bearded man looked up.
验尸。——针对一个前一天晚上自然流产的20周大胎儿。那个留胡子的男人抬头看了看。
"Who are you?" he wanted to know. I said I was a writer.
“你是谁？”他想知道。我说我是个作家。
"What are you writing?" he asked.
“你在写什么？”他问。
"A book about people who deal with death."
“一本关于那些处理死亡的人的书。”
"Death?" he said. "We don't deal with death. Go upstairs and talk to the oncologists. They deal with death. Their patients die all the time. Down here, we get them when they're dead. We never knew them, never talked to them, never had them as patients."
“死亡？”他说。“我们不处理死亡。去楼上找肿瘤科医生谈谈。他们才处理死亡。他们的病人一直在死。我们这里，我们收到他们的时候他们已经死了。我们从没认识过他们，从没和他们说过话，也从没把他们当过病人。”
As he spoke, he delicately unwound the child's small intestine, holding one end with the forceps, while gently pulling it between the blunt blades of another. Stripping it of its outer mucous membrane by opening and closing the forceps so rapidly that its pinchers behaved like the beak of a little bird nibbling at its feathers.
说话间，他精巧地解开了孩子的小肠，一只手用镊子夹住一端，另一只手用钝刀片轻轻拉开。他通过快速地开合镊子，将肠管的外粘膜剥离，镊子的咬合动作就像小鸟啄羽毛一样。
I thought, if you don't deal with death, what are you doing now? Isn't the kid dead? Aren't you taking him apart? What if I went upstairs and talked to the oncologists? Death? they'd say. We don't deal with death. We deal with the disease process. None of them would admit it.
我想，如果你不处理死亡，那你现在在干什么？孩子不是死了吗？你不是在把他拆解吗？如果我上楼去和肿瘤科医生谈呢？“死亡？”他们会说，“我们不处理死亡。我们处理的是疾病过程。”他们没人会承认的。
Do you think that the pathologists, who you visited, do you think that they actually did understand something about death that you didn't walking into it?
你认为你拜访的那些病理学家，他们真的比你更了解死亡吗？
I think they understood the body. But what they didn't understand, and what I don't think anyone can understand, is the difference between being alive and being dead. And how the spirit leaves the body, or how that thing that animates the body, evacuates it.
我认为他们了解身体。但他们不了解的，我认为没人能了解的，是生与死之间的区别。以及灵魂是如何离开身体的，或者说那个赋予身体活力的东西是如何撤离的。
Right, and that's at the center of our fascination with death, as lay people.
没错，而这正是我们这些外行对死亡产生迷恋的核心所在。
Oh, absolutely.
哦，当然。
It's interesting that both the pathologist and the homicide detective, they basically, in your description, you talk about how they're both looking at the body. They don't look at death. What they do is that they look at the body for clues, for what happened, for clues about the story that they're writing.
有趣的是，在你的描述中，病理学家和凶杀案侦探本质上都在注视尸体。他们并不注视死亡。他们所做的是在尸体中寻找线索，寻找发生了什么，寻找关于他们正在书写的故事的线索。
Yes, the read the body. They read the body. And the body tells a story. They learn how to work backwards, from the corpse to the murder.
是的，他们研读身体。他们研读身体，而身体讲述着一个故事。他们学会了如何倒推，从尸体推到谋杀。
But again, do you view what they're doing, that is, trying to take the body, trying to take the fact of this death and turn it into some kind of meaning, as being in any way parallel to what you were doing, coming on to the scene, trying to take the fact of these deaths and turn them into some sort of meaning? Or is it very different?
但同样，你是否认为他们所做的，即试图获取尸体，试图获取死亡的事实并将其转化为某种意义，与你当时的做法有任何相似之处？你来到现场，试图获取这些死亡的事实并将其转化为某种意义。还是说这两者截然不同？
I was looking for some transcendent meaning. I don't believe they ever were looking for any transcendent meaning. They had a body in question. The question is, how did the body reach them? I had another question, which is, how does one bear grief? And how does one bear loss? And how does one understand the inevitability of death as a fact of life?
我是在寻找某种超验的意义。我不相信他们曾经在寻找任何超验的意义。他们手里有一个待处理的尸体。问题是，身体是如何到达他们手里的？我有另一个问题，那就是：一个人如何承受悲伤？如何承受失落？以及一个人如何将死亡的不可避免性理解为生命的一个事实？
At one point you write that at the bottom of the hierarchy of death jobs is the slaughterhouse. Let me ask you to talk about what you found there.
你曾在书中写道，死亡工作的等级底层是屠宰场。让我请你谈谈你在那里发现了什么。
Well--
嗯——
You went to a slaughterhouse in Omaha.
你去了一家奥马哈的屠宰场。
Right, I went to a medium-size slaughterhouse, a beef kill. I think it killed 150 animals an hour. And the place was a mess. I mean, it was clean enough. They used germicides, and mechanical scrubbers, and so on at the end of every day. But when they were killing these animals and dismembering them, it was a howling, whistling, steam-filled chaos.
没错，我去了一家中等规模的屠宰场，是屠宰肉牛的。我想它们一小时屠宰150头牲畜。那个地方一团糟。我是说，它足够干净。他们每天结束时都会使用杀菌剂、机械洗涤器等等。但当他们宰杀并肢解这些动物时，那是一个充满嚎叫、哨声、蒸汽的混乱现场。
At one point when you were there, you're watching the person who actually kills the animals, and he operates an airgun, which presses a bolt into the animal's skull, and he hands it to you. He says, go ahead, try it.
你在那里的时候，曾看到那个真正负责宰杀动物的人，他操作着一把气枪，把一颗螺栓压进动物的头骨，他把它递给了你。他说：“来吧，试试看。”
Yeah, he handed it to me. He went down. He fell. And he'd lost his hard hat. He handed me this airgun, and I did it.
是的，他递给了我。它倒下了，掉落了。他弄丢了他的安全帽。他递给我那把气枪，我就做了。
You killed the steer.
你杀死了那头牛。
I killed the steer, yep.
我杀死了那头牛，是的。
Can I ask you to talk about how that changed your story, your perception of what you were writing?
能请你谈谈这如何改变了你的故事，改变了你对正在书写内容的看法吗？
Well, everyone, everyone wears some sort of protective clothing. And certainly, my protective clothing was that I was a watcher and a listener, not a participant. It was always those people who did those things, and I was always there standing, listening to them, thinking whatever I was thinking to myself and not doing it.
嗯，每个人，每个人都穿着某种防护服。毫无疑问，我的防护服就是：我是一个观察者和倾听者，而不是参与者。总是那些人做那些事，而我总是站在那里，听着他们，想着我心里所想的事，而不是亲手去做。
And actually, in an earlier scene, a detective says to you, everbody is a killer, everybody could be a killer. And you tell him, not me.
事实上，在前面的场景里，一位侦探对你说：“每个人都是杀手，每个人都可能是杀手。”而你告诉他：“我不是。”
Not me, yeah. Well, I mean, I thought I was protected. I mean, half my relatives had gone up the chimney in the Holocaust. I figured, I wasn't about to kill anyone. People like me had been on the receiving end of things. We didn't perpetuate the murders. We were the recipients. And it's a rather comforting, smug place to be existentially.
“我不是”，是的。好吧，我是说，我以为我有保护层。我是说，我的亲戚有一半在犹太人大屠杀中进了烟囱。我想，我绝不会去杀人。像我这样的人一直是被对待的对象。我们没有延续谋杀。我们是接受者。在生存层面上，这真是一个相当令人欣慰、自鸣得意的处境。
And so, once you killed the steer--
所以，当你杀死了那头牛之后——
Well, once I killed the steer, I figured the detective was right. I'd done it. It hadn't bothered me very much. And the fact that it hadn't bothered me very much was very scary.
好吧，一旦我杀了那头牛，我觉得那位侦探是对的。我做到了。这并没有太困扰我。而“它并没有太困扰我”这一事实，非常可怕。
Do you believe that being around death so much taints a person? Do you believe that it tainted you?
你是否相信，长期处于死亡之中会玷污一个人？你认为它玷污了你吗？
I think it taught me stuff. I think it does taint you to the extent that if you go out looking for this stuff, it'll come looking for you.
我认为它教会了我一些东西。我认为它确实会玷污你，程度在于，如果你出去寻找这些东西，它们也会来寻找你。
What do you mean by that?
你这话是什么意思？
What I mean is that you make your own fate. I think that, if you think for one minute that you can go out looking for death the way you might take a vacation, and that at the end of two weeks, you can turn the rental car in and get on the plane and leave, you're wrong.
我的意思是，你会造就你自己的命运。我认为，如果你有一分钟认为你可以像度假一样出去寻找死亡，并且在两周结束时，你可以交还租来的车，登上飞机离开，那你就错了。
Did you find that people who had these kinds of jobs viewed people who did not have these kinds of jobs and this contact with death at a distance?
你是否发现那些有这些工作的人，看待那些没有这些工作、没有与死亡保持距离接触的人时，有什么不同？
Oh, yes. I mean, I can remember the scene, which was when I was spending time with homicide detectives, they were called to a crime scene in which a man had ended his life, his own life, because of a broken heart. He'd put a .22 caliber bullet in his brain. The homicide detectives walked in and found him stretched out on his bed. He'd done a very nice job of cleaning the apartment beforehand. He'd left a series of heartbroken notes to the woman who'd broken his heart. They were handwritten. The i's were dotted with little open circles like bubbles. Very, very quickly, everyone who was living in this apartment complex came running. Including, eventually, the man's first wife and their children. And soon there were people weeping, and sobbing, and crying.
噢，是的。我是说，我记得那个场景，当时我和凶杀案侦探在一起，他们被叫到一个犯罪现场，一个男人因为心碎而结束了自己的生命。他用一颗.22口径的子弹射进了自己的大脑。凶杀案侦探走进去，发现他躺在床上。他事先把公寓打扫得干干净净。他给那个让他心碎的女人留了一系列令人心碎的便条。它们是手写的。字母“i”上的点画成了小圆圈，像气泡一样。很快，住在那个公寓大楼里的所有人都跑了过来。包括后来赶到的那个男人的前妻和他们的孩子。不久，到处都是哀悼、抽泣和哭喊的人。
And I can remember that a cab pulled up and out of the cab came the man's girlfriend. And she ran into the house, into the apartment. But then the cab driver got out. And the cab driver stood, with the door of his cab open, leaning on the top of the seal of the door, looking at all of this. And he looked very, very different from everyone around him. So different, the expression on his face was so different, that at the end of this scene, I asked the two homicide detectives I was with about that man.
我记得一辆出租车停下，那个男人的女朋友从车里走出来。她跑进了屋子，跑进了公寓。但随后出租车司机下车了。那个司机站在那里，出租车门开着，倚在门框上方，看着这一切。他看起来和周围的所有人都非常、非常不同。如此不同，他脸上的表情如此不同，以至于在这个场景结束后，我问了我身边的两位凶杀案侦探关于那个人的事。
I said that he was very strange. I didn't understand quite how, but there was something odd about him, and did they know him? And they said, yeah. He used to be a homicide detective. I mean, again, it's under the heading of useless and precious knowledge. The knowledge of these things separates you out from ordinary people.
我说他很奇怪。我不完全明白是怎么回事，但他身上有些古怪，他们认识他吗？他们说：“是的。他以前是个凶杀案侦探。”我是说，这再次归入“无用却珍贵知识”的范畴。这些事物的知识将你与普通人区分开来。
When you set out on your journey, you actually thought that these people would have some kind of knowledge, and that, by observing them and talking to them, you might learn something from them. But, in fact, it seems more what happened was, you simply got to see what they saw, that it wasn't the things people told you, and it wasn't the stories of the people who died, but simply being able to have contact with the physical fact, the concrete fact that this happens.
当你踏上旅程时，你其实认为这些人会拥有某种知识，并且通过观察他们、与他们交谈，你可能会从他们身上学到些什么。但事实上，似乎更多的情况是，你只是看到了他们所看到的，那不是人们告诉你的东西，也不是死者们的故事，而仅仅是能够接触到物理事实，接触到这种事确实会发生的具体事实。
Right, the concrete fact of death is the equivalent of either satanic or divine miracle. It's as unprecedented as birth. And most of us, in this world, in this country, don't even have the primary knowledge of such things.
没错，死亡的具体事实等同于撒旦或神圣的奇迹。它和出生一样史无前例。而我们大多数人，在这个世界上，在这个国家，甚至没有关于这类事情的基本认知。
We turn our eyes away from death.
我们将目光从死亡上移开。
Absolutely, absolutely.
绝对，绝对。
You said when we began that one of the reasons that you set out to go and see these things and see these people was that you wanted help in dealing with your own father's then-impending death. Did you find what you wanted? Did you find something that actually helped you?
你刚开始说，你出发去看看这些东西、见见这些人的原因之一是，你希望在应对你父亲当时即将到来的死亡时得到帮助。你找到了你想要的吗？你找到了真正帮助你的东西吗？
No, my father died demented and skeletal at the age of 94. His dying destroyed him. By the end, I was looking at someone who looked like my father but wasn't. Look, I think, Ira, it's the equivalent of-- I mean, I am married. I have two children. They're young adults. And I can remember going with my wife Elizabeth to Lamaze classes to prepare her for the birth of these children. But no matter what she was taught, once the contractions really began, the contractions began. And you can sit through all sorts of peaceful breathing exercises and visualization exercises, but once the contractions start, any sort of preparatory seminars do you little good.
没有，我父亲在94岁时在痴呆和骨瘦如柴中去世。他的离世摧毁了他。到了最后，我看着一个长得像我父亲但又不是他的人。听着，艾拉，这等同于——我是说，我结婚了。我有两个孩子。他们是年轻的成年人。我记得我和我的妻子伊丽莎白一起去上拉玛泽呼吸法课程，为这些孩子的出生做准备。但无论教了她什么，一旦真正的宫缩开始，宫缩就是开始了。你可以坐着完成各种平和的呼吸练习和视觉想象练习，但一旦宫缩开始，任何准备研讨会都帮不了你多少。
Do you feel like going through this experience and reflecting on it and writing, I mean, in one way or another, about death and things related to death since then, do you think that it's helped you in thinking about your own death?
你觉得经历这些并反思它，写下关于死亡以及自那以后与死亡相关的事情，你觉得它是否在你思考自己的死亡时有所帮助？
Sure. Absolutely. But, again, I've got to say, you can think about it all you like. It doesn't do you any good.
当然。绝对有。但同样，我不得不说，你可以随心所欲地思考它。它并不能为你带来任何好处。
Michael Lesy, author of The Forbidden Zone , and other books.
迈克尔·莱西，《禁区》及其他书籍的作者。
Well, coming up, David Sedaris, Smuggler, a fireman, and others in the business of death. That's in a minute, when our program continues.
好的，接下来的节目有大卫·塞达里斯、走私者、一位消防员以及其他死亡生意中的人们。一分钟后，节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers, and performers, and documentary producers to contribute stories on the theme. Today's program-- The Business Of Death. Stories about people who are near death, every day, in their jobs, and what they see that we don't.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们当然都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者和纪录片制片人来贡献关于这个主题的故事。今天的节目——《死亡生意》。关于那些每天在工作中离死亡很近的人们，以及他们所看到的我们所看不到的事物的故事。
Act Three, Fireman. One of the things that Michael Lesy wrote about when he went with homicide detectives out on their cases, is that when they find a corpse, they don't think about the more existential questions about death. They do their jobs. The corpse, to them, is primarily a source of clues to solve the case. Firemen also see the body but cannot dwell on it if they're going to do their jobs. Larry Brown was a firefighter in Oxford, Mississippi. This is from his book, On Fire . Actor Michael Stumm reads.
第三幕，《消防员》。迈克尔·莱西在随同凶杀案侦探办案时写道，当他们发现尸体时，他们不会去想关于死亡的那些存在主义问题。他们是在做自己的工作。对他们来说，尸体主要是破案的线索来源。消防员也会看到尸体，但如果他们想完成工作，就不能对此耿耿于怀。拉里·布朗是密西西比州牛津市的一名消防员。这是选自他的书《着火了》。由演员迈克尔·斯图姆朗读。
The worst thing I ever saw was either two babies and their grandmother burnt to death, to nothing, to just charred black lumps that had to be picked up out of smoking rubble, or a guy who wasn't dead yet, who was mashed half in two by a truck. I saw a lot of death, and I worked at a small department in a little Mississippi town. It may sound cold, but the dead who were already gone never bothered me as much as the living ones, who were in great amounts of pain and shock, who had to be assured that, yes, in fact, they were not going to die, but were going to live if they'd just take it easy and relax.
我见过的最糟糕的事情，要么是两个婴儿和他们的祖母被烧死，化为乌有，变成必须从冒烟的废墟中拾起的烧焦的黑色肿块，要么是一个还没死、但被卡车压成两截的男人。我见过很多死亡，我在密西西比州一个小镇的消防部门工作。这听起来可能很冷酷，但那些已经死去的死者从未像活人那样困扰我，那些活着的、身受重伤和处于震惊中的人们，必须有人向他们保证：是的，事实上，他们不会死，如果他们放松下来，他们会活下去的。
That day when those two little kids and their grandmother burned up, I was out at the elementary school giving a fire extinguisher class with the Chief, and somebody else had to drive my pumper to the fire. We got the call during the class, and I rode with Uncle Chiefy out there. And we saw, right away, the house was falling in with fire. I was breaking in a rookie and nobody had even told him to put his gloves on. He stood there in the yard and did all he could, and blistered his hands badly while using an inch and a half hose. Then the house fell in, and we were told that there were people inside.
那天，当那两个小孩和他们的祖母烧死时，我正在小学和队长一起进行灭火器教学课程，别人不得不开着我的消防车去救火。我们在上课时接到了电话，我坐着叔叔（队长）的车赶了过去。我们一眼就看到那栋房子在火海中倒塌。我当时正在带一个新兵，没人告诉他戴上手套。他站在院子里尽其所能，结果在使用1.5英寸水管时双手严重起泡。接着房子塌了，有人告诉我们里面还有人。
It was late in the evening by then, winter. The ruins were smoking. Cops tried to keep screaming family members back. The smoke shifted in the rubble and we all stood back, dreading what had to be done. We entered the back side of the house and no words were said. The police had set out the body bags for us. The smoke moved among the charred timbers and piles of ashes and glowing embers, and we had to find the things we were looking for. It was hard to tell, everything being so burned, everything looking so much alike.
那是傍晚时分了，冬天。废墟还在冒烟。警察试图拦住尖叫的家属。烟雾在瓦砾和灰堆中飘散，我们都退缩了，恐惧着必须要做的事情。我们从房子的后部进入，没有人说话。警察已经为我们准备好了尸袋。烟雾在烧焦的木头、灰烬堆和炽热的余烬中移动，我们必须找到我们要找的东西。很难分辨，一切都烧得太严重了，一切看起来都那么相似。
There was silence among us as our people lifted the bodies out. The children were so small. I thought of my own. No words were said. I wondered what my life would ever come to. The lights of all the emergency vehicles blinked out on the street. And even the cops wanted to turn their faces away. I know they have a hard time. People mess with them, and they have to mess with drunks, and, once in awhile, they have to look at something with us.
当我们的队员把尸体抬出来时，我们之间一片寂静。孩子们太小了。我想到我自己的孩子。没有人说话。我想知道我的人生最终会变成什么样。所有急救车辆的灯在街道上闪烁。甚至警察也想转过头去。我知道他们过得也很辛苦。人们找他们麻烦，他们不得不处理醉汉，偶尔，他们还得和我们一起看着某些东西。
A few days later, the man who was the father of the dead children came into the station to try and get his hands on a copy of the fire report, so he could turn it over to his insurance company. A poker game was going on at our big table in the middle of the kitchen. This man had his cap in his hands. And his clothes were ragged. The betting went on, our boys never looking crossways at him, not knowing who he was. Their voices got louder while the man stood there patiently, waiting for the Chief to find the report in the file cabinet. The man looked humbled by what had happened to him. His children had probably been buried quickly.
几天后，死掉孩子们的父亲来到消防站，试图弄到一份火灾报告的复印件，好交给保险公司。我们厨房中间的大桌子上正在进行一场扑克游戏。这个男人手里拿着帽子，衣服褴褛。博弈继续着，我们的人甚至没有斜眼看他，不知道他是谁。他们的声音越来越大，而那个男人耐心地站在那里，等着队长在档案柜里找到报告。这个男人看起来因为发生在他身上的事而感到卑微。他的孩子们可能已经被匆匆下葬了。
The poker game went on. And the man kept standing there with his cap in his hands, until finally, mercifully, Uncle Chiefy found the report and took the man back to the Xerox machine to make a copy of it. I never asked them to stop the game.
扑克游戏继续进行。男人一直拿着帽子站在那里，直到最后，仁慈地，叔叔找到了报告，带那个男人去复印机那里复印了一份。我从没叫他们停止比赛。
Sometimes there was a weird callousness about the work we did. We couldn't let it get too close to us, because we didn't want to be touched by it. We didn't talk much about the bad ones. When they happened, we dealt with them. Then we went back and ate, or watched a movie, or went on another call, or washed the trucks, or polished the chrome. We got through our shifts, and then we went home and went fishing, or hunting, or made love to our wives, or played with our children. We hoped the bad things we saw would never claim us. We hoped we wouldn't die in smoke and flames or torn steel, like the people we couldn't save.
有时我们做的工作有一种奇怪的冷漠。我们不能让它离我们太近，因为我们不想被它触及。我们很少谈论那些糟糕的事情。当它们发生时，我们就处理掉。然后我们回去吃饭，看电影，或者出下一次警，或者洗车，或者擦拭镀铬件。我们熬过了轮班，然后回家去钓鱼、打猎、和妻子做爱，或者和孩子们玩耍。我们希望我们所见的糟糕事情永远不会降临到我们身上。我们希望我们不会像我们无法拯救的人那样，死在烟雾、火焰或扭曲的钢铁中。
Michael Stumm, reading from Larry Brown's book, On Fire.
迈克尔·斯图姆，朗读自拉里·布朗的书《着火了》。
Act Four, Smugglers. Well, David Sedaris is a frequent contributor to This American Life , and for years has been an occasional contributor to NPR's Morning Edition . And for years, there have been two stories that he has tried to get onto Morning Edition without any success at all. These days he is on a book tour for his book, Naked . And he reads these two stories wherever he goes, along with special modified versions of the stories that he also tried to smuggle on the air, without any success.
第四幕，《走私者》。大卫·塞达里斯是《美国生活》的常客，多年来一直是NPR《早间版》的特约撰稿人。多年来，他一直有两篇故事想在《早间版》播出，但从未成功。如今，他正在为自己的书《裸体》进行巡回宣传。他走到哪里都会朗读这两篇故事，还有他试图通过无线电播出的修改后的特殊版本，但也从未成功。
One of these two stories actually touches on people in the business of death. So this seems like, at last, at last, radio audience of America, this is the perfect opportunity to put these on the air.
这两篇故事中的一篇实际上触及了死亡行业的人。所以，终于，终于，美国的广播听众们，这是把它放到广播上的绝佳机会。
And then, I just wanted to read these. I had a couple things that I was dragging around for a while. But I tried to get on Morning Edition and they just wouldn't let them on for anything. And so these are just two of the little things.
然后，我只是想读读这些。我有一些东西已经拖了好一会儿了。但我试着让《早间版》播，他们怎么也不肯让它们上。所以这只是其中的两件小事。
I had dinner with Jean and Evelyn. Both of them work for the Academy of Orthopaedic Surgeons, where they plan the annual meetings. Jean told me that hotels have a rule stating you're not allowed to display a cadaver in any room where food is being served. It never occurred to me that someone might be forced to make such a rule, let alone enforce it. But both Jean and Evelyn have snuck the dead into meeting rooms.
我和简还有伊芙琳一起吃了晚饭。她们都在骨科医师学会工作，负责策划年会。简告诉我，酒店有一条规定，禁止在任何供应食物的房间展示尸体。我从没想过有人会被迫制定这样的规则，更不用说执行它了。但简和伊芙琳都曾把死者偷偷带进会议室。
Evelyn once traveled with half a woman. She named her Judy and carried her around in a refrigerated suitcase. Jean once had to sneak an entire cadaver into the San Francisco Fairmont. She said they dressed the corpse in casual clothing and mussed up his hair, so he'd look drunk. Then they carried him into the meeting room, supported by two sober doctors. Jean said the only hard part was finding two sober doctors at the convention.
伊芙琳曾经随身携带过“半个女人”。她给她起名叫朱迪，装在冷藏箱里随身携带。简曾经不得不把一具完整的尸体偷偷带进旧金山的费尔蒙酒店。她说他们给尸体穿上了休闲装，弄乱了他的头发，这样他看起来就像喝醉了一样。然后他们由两名清醒的医生搀扶着，把他带进了会议室。简说，唯一困难的部分就是在大会上找到两名清醒的医生。
At another meeting, a surgeon heard that Jean and Evelyn had a refrigerator in their room and knocked late at night asking if he could store a couple of knees until morning. His own refrigerator was packed with elbows and tendons, and he had no more room. I guess when you check that little square on your driver's licenses, there's no telling where you'll wind up. Parts of you may eventually check into some of the finest hotels of this country.
在另一次会议上，一位外科医生听说简和伊芙琳的房间里有个冰箱，深夜敲门问能不能帮他存几个膝盖直到早上。他自己的冰箱里塞满了肘部和肌腱，没空间了。我想，当你勾选驾照上那个小方框时，你永远不知道自己最终会去向何方。你的一部分身体可能会入住该国一些最好的酒店。
All right, now, that was the first story. Now, we come to the second story that David wasn't able to get onto Morning Edition , and I have to admit, this has nothing to do with our theme. But you know, we've come this far, you and me. We might as well continue down this path.
好的，那是第一个故事。现在，我们来到了大卫无法在《早间版》播出的第二个故事，我不得不承认，这和我们的主题无关。但你知道，既然我们已经走到了这一步，你和我。我们不妨继续走下去。
We had Easter dinner at John's house. A big afternoon meal, which we ate in his backyard. Everyone had taken their places at the table, when I excused myself to visit the bathroom. And there, in the toilet, was the absolute biggest turd I have ever seen in my life, no toilet paper or anything, just this thick and coiled specimen.
我们在约翰家吃了复活节晚餐。一场丰盛的午餐，我们在他的后院吃。大家都在餐桌旁落座时，我借口去洗手间。结果，在马桶里，有我这辈子见过的绝对最大的屎，没有卫生纸什么的，只有这根粗大卷曲的标本。
I flushed the toilet and the big turd roused around. It budged and bobbed a little, but that was it. This thing wasn't going anywhere. Just then someone knocked on the door, and I started to panic. Just a minute!
我冲了马桶，那根大便动了动。它动了动，晃了晃，但也仅此而已。这东西哪儿也没去。就在这时有人敲门，我开始恐慌。“等一下！”
At an early age, my mother sat me down and explained that everyone has bowel movements. Everyone, she said, even the President and his wife, everyone in the world, everyone but me. And I could picture them all, everyone from Red Skelton to Lady Bird Johnson, but something this big? Just a minute!
我很小的时候，我母亲就把我叫到一边解释说，每个人都会排便。每个人，她说，连总统和他的妻子，全世界的每个人，除了我。我能想象他们所有人，从雷·斯凯尔顿到伯德夫人，但是这么大？“等一下！”
And I seriously considered lifting this turd out of the toilet and tossing it out the window. I honestly considered it, but John lives on the ground floor, and a dozen people were seated at a picnic table 10 feet away. And these were people who would surely investigate and gather round. And there I'd be, trying to explain that it wasn't mine! But why would I bother throwing it out the window if it wasn't mine? No one would have believed me. Just a minute!
我认真考虑过把这坨屎从马桶里捞出来扔出窗外。我确实考虑过，但约翰住在底楼，十几个人坐在10英尺外的野餐桌旁。这些人肯定会调查并围过来。而我就得站在那里，试图解释那不是我的！但如果不是我的，我为什么要费劲把它扔出窗外呢？没人会相信我。等一下！
And I scrambled for the plunger and used it to break the turd into manageable pieces. And even then, I had to flush twice just to get rid of it. It was Janet at the door, and she said, well, it's about time. And I was left thinking that the person who left the huge turd had no problem with it, so why did I? And later, at the table, I examined each guest, trying to figure who was capable.
我翻找皮搋子，把它用来把大便分成易于处理的小块。即便如此，我也必须冲两次才能把它弄走。门口是珍妮特，她说：“好了，终于好了。”我当时在想，那个留下这坨巨屎的人对此一点也没问题，为什么我有问题呢？后来在桌上，我审视了每一位客人，试图找出谁有这个能力。
And they rejected that time after time, so then-- and there's no foul language in it or anything-- so I rewrote it. I rewrote it, trying to slip it past them as lighthearted verse.
他们一次又一次拒绝了，所以——里面没有脏话什么的——所以我重写了它。我重写了它，试图把它作为轻松的诗句偷运过去。
I had dinner last night with Evelyn and Jean, at a place specializing in island cuisine. Jean had the bass and Evelyn, sturgeon. The two of them work for a large group of surgeons. They handle the dues and plan the convention. It calls for a great deal of anal retention. It's difficult work setting up the exhibits. These hotels have rules that strictly prohibit displaying cadavers in large meeting halls where people are eating. It's strict protocol.
我昨晚和伊芙琳还有简在一家主打岛屿菜系的餐馆吃了晚饭。简点了鲈鱼，伊芙琳点了鲟鱼。她们两个为一个大型外科医生团队工作。她们处理会费并策划大会。这需要极度的“肛门期固着”。设置展品是很困难的工作。这些酒店有严格规定，严禁在供应食物的大型会议厅内展示尸体。这是严格的礼仪。
It makes sense to me, but Evelyn and Jean have reason to think that this law is obscene. Because of their work, they both snuck dead bodies through dining halls featuring stuffed manicottis and beef tenderloin. It was Evelyn's duty to carry a corpse, half a woman named Judy, around in a suitcase packed with dry ice.
我觉得有道理，但伊芙琳和简有理由认为这条法律很荒谬。因为工作的原因，她们都曾把尸体偷运进以塞满意式肉馅卷饼和嫩牛肉为特色的餐厅。伊芙琳的职责是把一具尸体——一个叫朱迪的半个女人——装在装满干冰的行李箱里到处走。
That's nothing, her friend said, I have once or twice snuck into hotels with a full-grown dead body. We dressed a guy up, then we made him look shoddy. I untucked his shirt and rumpled his suit, then mussed up his hair and unlaced one boot. To make him look drunk, right? The guy looked like hell. We carried him right through the Fairmont Hotel, supported by doctors. I searched the place over. The hard part was finding two doctors still sober.
“那没什么，”她的朋友说，“我有一次或两次偷偷带着完整的尸体进酒店。我们给一个家伙穿好衣服，然后让他看起来很寒酸。我解开他的衬衫，揉皱了他的西装，然后弄乱了他的头发，解开了一只靴子。为了让他看起来像醉酒，对吧？那家伙看起来糟透了。我们由医生搀扶着，把他直接带过了费尔蒙酒店。我把整个地方翻遍了。困难的部分是找到两个还清醒的医生。”
She told of the time she once found herself lending her hotel room, cooler for storing a tendon. A doctor had visited, begging her, please, I'd use my own fridge, but it's chock full of knees. When surgeons convene, they come packed with parts, like kidneys and spleens, spinal columns and hearts.
她讲述了有一次她发现自己把酒店房间的冷藏箱借给别人存放肌腱。一位医生拜访了她，哀求说：“拜托，我想用我自己的冰箱，但里面塞满了膝盖。”当外科医生开会时，他们装满了器官，比如肾脏和脾脏、脊柱和心脏。
It makes you think twice about checking that square, that space on your license whereby you swear to offer your body to science so others might see with your eyes, for the first time, their brothers, or love with your heart, or pee with your kidney, kick with your foot, or bend on your mid-knee.
这让你在勾选那个方框时会三思，即驾照上的那个空间，你发誓愿意贡献你的身体给科学，这样别人可能会通过你的眼睛第一次看到他们的兄弟，或者用你的心去爱，或者用你的肾脏去排泄，用你的脚去踢，或者用你的膝盖去弯曲。
It's something to think about when you're alive, the thought, when you're dead, there's a chance you'll arrive at four star hotels, cut up into pieces, displayed near a chart or a plastic prosthesis. Your lung or your liver will grace the convention, the objects of pure undivided attention.
当你活着时，这值得思考；当你死后，你有机会到达五星级酒店，被切成碎片，展示在图表或塑料假肢旁。你的肺或肝脏将为大会增色，成为纯粹、全神贯注的对象。
And then, we had Easter dinner at John's house on Irving. A big sit-down meal in daytime's unnerving. For me, anyway, I like to eat later. I took some roast lamb, a couple potaters, and carried my plate outside to the lawn, to a table he'd covered in bright pink chiffon. I'd had a few beers and a glass of chablis and thought, before eating, I might want to pee.
然后，我们在欧文街约翰家吃了复活节晚餐。白天的正式大餐让人不安。对我来说，反正我喜欢晚点吃。我拿了一些烤羊肉，几块土豆，把盘子端到外面的草坪上，放在他盖着亮粉色雪纺的桌子上。我喝了几杯啤酒和一杯夏布利葡萄酒，心想，吃之前，我可能想小便。
I stepped back inside, down the hall to the toilet. The door creaked behind me. John needed to oil it. Unzipping my fly then, I glance in the bowl and spotted a turd there, a huge tootsie roll. The thing was gigantic, all coiled and massive. I flushed the john then, but this turd was impassive.
我走回屋里，沿着走廊去马桶。门在我身后吱呀作响。约翰得给它上油了。解开拉链时，我瞄了一眼马桶，发现里面有一坨大便，一个巨大的“图茨卷”。那东西太巨大了，卷曲着，又厚重。我冲了厕所，但这坨大便很冷漠。
It budged and it bobbed, but the large stool remained long after the water had spiraled and drained. This stool was the largest that I'd ever seen. It looked like a log or a toy submarine. I flushed it again, and the action repeated. The feces remained while the water retreated.
它动了动，晃了晃，但这大便在水螺旋消失后依然存在。这是我见过最大的大便。它看起来像一根原木或玩具潜水艇。我又冲了一次，动作重复。当水退去时，粪便依然存在。
Someone came to the door then, they knocked and they pounded. Just a second! I cried, panic-struck and dumbfounded. A bowel movement's normal, my mom once said, hesitant. Everyone has them, why, even the President. But something this big was beyond comprehension.
有人敲门，他们敲得咚咚响。“等一下！”我喊道，惊慌失措，目瞪口呆。“排便很正常，”我妈曾说，犹豫不决。每个人都有，哎呀，连总统也有。但这么大东西太令人无法理解了。
I'm coming! I yelled. It was my sole intention to get rid of this turd. But how could I do it? I said to myself, then what if I threw it out of the window? But to my dismay, the guests were all sitting just 10 feet away. They'd look up from their plates and in no time would gather around this big turd. And meanwhile I'd brather, it wasn't my doing! This wasn't my stool!
“来了！”我喊道。我的唯一意图是除掉这坨大便。但我该怎么做呢？我对自己说，扔出窗外怎么样？但令我沮丧的是，客人们都坐在10英尺外。他们会抬头从盘子里看到，很快就会围住这坨大便。而同时我会解释说，这不是我干的！这不是我的大便！
No one would believe me. They'd think me a fool. They'd look at me funny and think I was lying. Why toss a turd if it's not even mine? Just a second! I shouted. And plunger in hand, I worked with the handle and tried to disband this turd into pieces. I broke it to bits. Then flushed twice to wash away all the small [BLEEP].
没人会相信我。他们会以为我是个傻瓜。他们会奇怪地看着我，以为我在撒谎。如果不是我的，为什么要扔掉大便？“等一下！”我喊道。我手里拿着皮搋子，用把手操作，试图把这坨大便拆解成碎片。我把它弄碎了。然后冲了两次水，把所有小东西冲掉。
I opened the door then, to find my friend Janet. While waiting she'd eaten a whole pomegranate. It's about time, she said. And I left the room thinking, the person who left that huge turd in there, stinkin', walked off with no problem, so why the big deal? I picked up my fork and returned to my meal. The thought of that turd, though, it was inescapable. I examined each guest then, wondering who might be capable. Thanks.
我打开门，看到了我的朋友珍妮特。等待期间她吃了一整个石榴。“终于好了，”她说。我离开房间时心想，那个把那坨大便留在那儿、臭气熏天的人，走得一点问题也没有，那为什么要大惊小怪？我拿起叉子回到餐桌前。不过，那坨大便的想法依然挥之不去。我审视了每一位客人，想知道谁可能有这个能力。谢谢。
David Sedaris, author of the book, Naked.
大卫·塞达里斯，《裸体》一书的作者。
Well, that song brings us perfectly to Act Five. Act Five, The Happiest Death Worker. What's the point of listening to public radio if you don't occasionally learn a new word? Well, as a public service, to give you your money's worth, we know that many of you gave in the last fund drive, here's today's word.
好的，那首歌把我们完美地带到了第五幕。第五幕，《最快乐的死亡工作者》。如果你不偶尔学个新词，听公共广播还有什么意义呢？嗯，作为一种公共服务，为了让你觉得钱花得值，我们知道你们很多人在上次募款活动中都捐了钱，这是今天的词。
Enucleator.
眼球摘除者（Enucleator）。
How do you spell that?
你怎么拼那个词？
E-U-N-U-C-L-E-A-- I don't know. I have to write it down. You can't ask me that.
E-U-N-U-C-L-E-A——我不知道。我得把它写下来。你不能问我这个。
Lou Zeidberg is an enucleator himself. It means that he removes people's eyes for a living, the eyes of dead people. He works for an eye bank in New York City. Meema Sapdola talked him into an interview.
卢·扎伊德伯格本人就是一位眼球摘除者。这意味着他以摘除人们的眼睛为生，死人的眼睛。他在纽约市的一家眼库工作。米玛·萨普多拉说服他接受了采访。
Lou tells me I can tag along with him on Saturday night. But he warns me, I don't want you fainting and cracking your dome on the floor, because I'm going to have to wipe up the blood. Lou talks like that. I'll take you places you've never been before, he says. The Brooklyn medical examiner's office, think of the worst scene you can, it's worse than that. Let me put it this way, when you walk out of there, you want to burn your shoes.
卢告诉我，周六晚上我可以跟着他。但他警告我：“我可不想你晕倒后把头磕在地板上，因为我得清理血迹。”卢说话就是这样。他说：“我会带你去你从未去过的地方。布鲁克林法医办公室，想想你能想到的最糟糕的场景，那比那更糟。我这么说吧，当你走出那里时，你会想烧掉你的鞋子。”
In the end, the director of the eye bank decides I can't go with Lou. Eye donations are desperately needed, and they don't want me doing a story that'll scare people. So on a bright spring day, Lou takes me to this place I've never been before, a small office on the 10th floor of the Manhattan Eye, Ear, and Throat Hospital. It looks like any other office you've been in, except for a small lab in the back, and a sink where they scrub-up for procedures.
最终，眼库的负责人决定我不能跟着卢。眼角膜捐赠极度紧缺，他们不想让我做一个吓跑人们的报道。所以在一个明媚的春日，卢带我去了我从未去过的地方：曼哈顿眼耳喉医院10楼的一间小办公室。它看起来和你去过的任何其他办公室一样，除了后面有一个小实验室，还有一个用来在手术前刷手的洗手池。
So I have to put this on and scrub in.
所以我也得穿上这个，并进行刷手准备。
Lou's completely decked out in blue surgical cap, blue surgical mask, eye shield.
卢全副武装：蓝色手术帽、蓝色手术口罩、护目镜。
Lou is tall and handsome. He makes me think of a tough-talking version of Gary Cooper. In college he used to be a boxer. The procedure he's doing is to remove a cornea from a donor's eye. Usually it's just the cornea, or sometimes the white part of the eye, the sclera, that gets transplanted.
卢身材高大，英俊潇洒。他让我想起一个说话强硬版的加里·库珀。大学时他曾是名拳击手。他做的手术是从捐赠者的眼中摘除眼角膜。通常只是角膜，有时是眼球的白色部分（巩膜）被移植。
Now he's opening a package, another blue, sterile--
现在他正在打开包装，另一个蓝色的，无菌的——
These are towels, just to dry my hands when I'm done scrubbing in.
这些是毛巾，我刷手结束后用来擦手的。
There's a ritual to eye transplantation. Lou lays out the blue cloths and sterilized tools. I'm impure and must stand away from the sterile field.
眼球移植有一套仪式。卢铺好蓝色的布，放好消毒过的工具。我不洁，必须远离无菌区。
So the first thing I do is I scrape-- any bacteria that might be on the edge, I would clear it away using a scalpel.
所以我做的第一件事是刮除——边缘上可能有任何细菌，我会用手术刀清理掉。
Lou lays the eyeball on a strip of gauze. He expertly rolls the eye, like a piece of sushi, and holds it firmly. The eye peeks out at us.
卢把眼球放在一块纱布条上。他熟练地滚动眼球，像卷寿司一样，稳稳地抓住它。眼球向我们窥视。
We always talk about, oh, eyes have so much expression. Do eyes ever have any expression at all, of the eyes that you're removing from either a donor, or once you have it out?
我们总是谈论“哦，眼睛有那么多的表现力”。眼睛真的有表现力吗，就是你摘除的那些捐赠者或者一旦取出来的那些眼睛？
Of all the procedures I've done, the biggest change in feeling I've got, or the biggest education about death that I've got, is that a person's body is just that. And that everything that makes up the person that you know is gone once that person dies.
在我做过的所有手术中，我获得的最大感受变化，或者说关于死亡的最大的教育是：人的身体仅仅是身体。一旦人死了，你所认识的那个人的所有组成部分都消失了。
He snips around the cornea with tiny curved scissors, then lifts it off the eye to reveal a soft, bright, blue iris.
他用弯曲的小剪刀在角膜周围剪了一圈，然后将其从眼睛上揭起，露出柔软、明亮的蓝色虹膜。
Oh, it's like you lifted off the cap of the cornea, and it's so much more beautiful now underneath.
哦，就像你掀开了角膜盖子，下面现在看起来美多了。
This cornea was somewhat opaque, so you weren't able to see all the true blueness of this person's iris. And when I lifted it up, a lot of people say, it really looks like I'm just taking a contact lens off of the eye. The eye is really an amazing structure, the way it's so delicately put together. And it's really tough, in one way. I mean the white part of your eye is a thick-- it almost feels like rubber. And behind that--
这枚角膜有些混浊，所以你无法看到这个人的虹膜所有的真实蓝色。当我揭起它时，很多人说，它看起来真的就像我刚从眼睛上取下隐形眼镜。眼睛真的是一个惊人的结构，它的精致程度让人赞叹。而且从某种程度上说，它真的很坚硬。我是说，你眼睛的白色部分是一层厚厚的——感觉就像橡胶。而在那后面——
As we're standing in the lab, a coworker comes in to grab medical supplies from the fridge. You have a donor, Lou asks him?
当我们站在实验室里时，一位同事进来从冰箱里拿医疗用品。“你有捐赠者吗？”卢问他。
You have a donor?
“你有捐赠者吗？”
Yep.
“有。”
Where  are you going?
“你要去哪儿？”
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[模糊不清]
You bummed you're going to miss that staff meeting?
“你难过会错过那个员工会议吗？”
No. [INAUDIBLE]
“不。”[听不清]
They have another donor, meaning another person in New York just died. Later, the education director tells me they get 1,200 eyes every year. 600 people who die, I say. 600 people who donate, she corrects me. Lou's enucleated 100 of them.
他们还有另一个捐赠者，这意味着纽约又死了一个人。后来，教育主任告诉我，他们每年收到1200只眼睛。“600人死亡，”我说。“600人捐赠，”她纠正我。卢摘除了其中的100只。
To be honest, before I started doing this work, like most Americans, I didn't really think about death.
老实说，在开始这项工作之前，像大多数美国人一样，我并没有真正思考过死亡。
Now, seeing so many dead people, old people, teenagers, little kids, it's easy for Lou to picture his own body spread out on a slab.
现在，看到这么多死者，老年人、青少年、小孩，卢很容易想象自己的身体躺在平板上的样子。
I definitely take health and safety a lot more seriously than I did when I was a young man. Definitely drive a little bit more carefully, always wear seat belts. And then also, just, I eat well and don't smoke or drink alcohol, things like that.
我确实比年轻时更认真地对待健康和安全。开车肯定小心多了，总是系安全带。然后，我也吃得好，不抽烟不喝酒，诸如此类。
Lou's only 26. And when I met Lou at a party six months ago, he had a beer in one hand, a cigarette in the other. He tells me he's quit since then. There's something about this job that makes him think he's supposed to be a saint. A benevolent angel, scrubbed and sterilized, calling the next of kin and calmly asking when he can remove the eyes of their loved ones.
卢才26岁。六个月前我在一个聚会上遇到他时，他一手拿着啤酒，一手拿着香烟。他告诉我从那以后他就戒了。这份工作有些东西让他觉得他应该成为圣人。一个仁慈的天使，洗得干干净净，消毒完毕，打电话给近亲，平静地询问什么时候可以摘除他们亲人的眼睛。
Do you ever look down at this person, whose eyes you're removing, and think, this is someone's mother, this is someone's brother?
你会看着这个被你摘除眼睛的人，想：这是某人的母亲，这是某人的兄弟吗？
Yeah, every time, I always think that. And I just try and provide a little bit of comfort in this otherwise awful experience.
是的，每一次，我都会这么想。我只是试着在这种否则会非常可怕的经历中提供一点点慰藉。
I mean you, in a sense, of every profession that deals directly with death, yours has got to be the most positive. You and anyone else who's dealing with transplanting organs of any kind. Because everyone else, the doctors losing the patient, the person at the funeral home, I mean, it's just death. There's nothing particularly positive there. It's interesting, have you ever--
我是说，从某种意义上说，在所有直接处理死亡的职业中，你的工作绝对是最积极的。你和任何处理移植器官的人都是如此。因为其他人，失去病人的医生，殡仪馆的人——我是说，那只是死亡。那里没有什么特别积极的东西。很有趣，你有没有——
I have to disagree. Because I think that a funeral home does provide a very important service. I mean it's a service that everybody does need. And to attempt to do such a hard job, I think is noble in and of itself.
我不得不反对。因为我认为殡仪馆确实提供了非常重要的服务。我是说，这是每个人都需要的一项服务。我认为试图从事这样一份艰苦的工作，本身就是高尚的。
Are you noble?
你高尚吗？
I don't know. I'm fortunate to have such a benevolent job. And I try to do it as well as I can.
我不知道。我很幸运能从事这样一份仁慈的工作。我试着尽可能把它做好。
The dictionary says to enucleate means to remove an eye. An older meaning of the word is to elucidate, to explain. After I leave Lou's office, I check my driver's license to see if I ever filled out the organ donor section on the back. I hadn't. I stare at my license and hesitate. Checking this one tiny box means admitting that I'm going to die. I sign up. I might as well tattoo a recycling symbol on my chest. I'm ready to be processed.
词典说“摘除”（enucleate）意思是摘除眼睛。这个词的一个更古老的含义是阐明（elucidate），即解释。离开卢的办公室后，我查看了我的驾照，看看我是否填写了背面的器官捐赠部分。我没有。我盯着我的驾照犹豫了。勾选这个小方框意味着承认我会死。我签了名。我可能还会像在胸口纹上回收标志一样。我准备好被处理了。
On the subway after the interview, all I see are eyeballs. Eyes stupidly rolling around in people's heads, reading papers, checking watches. The man opposite me with pale blue eyes blinks. His eyes shuttle left and right as he watches the subway tunnel fly past. A woman, with glazed over brown eyes, stares at an ad for corn and bunion removal. I think of Lou delicately snipping away at their eyeballs, lifting off their corneas, peeling away the sclera.
面试后的地铁上，我看到的全是眼球。眼睛愚蠢地在人们的脑袋里打转，阅读报纸，查看手表。对面那个有着浅蓝色眼睛的男人眨了眨眼。当他注视着地铁隧道飞驰而过时，他的眼睛左右梭巡。一个褐色眼睛、眼神呆滞的女人正盯着一则玉米和鸡眼切除广告。我想着卢精巧地剪开他们的眼球，取下角膜，剥开巩膜。
Well, our program was produced today by Paul Tough and myself, with Julie Snyder, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Margie Rochlin, Jack Kitt, and Sarah Vowell, who also found most of the music for today's program. Other musical help today from John Connors. Thanks today to KUOW for their recording of David Sedaris.
好的，我们的节目今天由保罗·塔夫和我自己制作，朱莉·斯奈德、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与制作。特约编辑玛吉·罗克林、杰克·基特和莎拉·沃威尔，她也为今天的节目找到了大部分音乐。今天来自约翰·康纳斯的音乐帮助。感谢KUOW提供大卫·塞达里斯的录音。
If you would like a cassette of this program or any other This American Life program, well, it only costs $10. Call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Our email address, radio@ well.com.
如果你想要本节目或任何其他《美国生活》节目的磁带，嗯，只需10美元。致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，312-832-3380。再次重复，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是radio@well.com。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助信息]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who insists, insists, insists--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他坚持、坚持、坚持——
It wasn't mine.
这不是我的。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。